le loueur avis l'atelier des chefs de
nombreuses entreprises ont accéléré leur
virage digital dans cette crise
sanitaire à l'image de l'enseigné de
surgelés picard bonjour cathy collart
jachère bonjour serait là un petit
chaque année installez-vous merci quand
vous arrivez à la tête de puits car on
est en juin juin 2020 et on est en plein
coeur de la crise sanitaire et vous fait
ce constat lucide implacable diront
certains que picard est en retard sur le
digital c'est ça le constat quand vous
arrivez oui puisque comme je dirai tout
commerçant fait on a assisté à
l'explosion des achats en ligne aussi
sur les produits surgelés pendant le
premier confinement et vous n'étiez pas
prêts et nous n'étions pas prêts puisque
ont livré à l'époque 25 % du territoire
français c'est parce que c'est plus le
cas c'est 100 % aujourd'hui oui bon
voilà et lors du prime confinement vous
n'ait pas pu honorer toutes vos
commandes à toutes les commandes des
clients ce qui comme problématique on
entre dans un délai relativement long
pour ce qui est de la nourriture
effectivement bon donc à votre arrivée
vous vous dites je mets paquet sur
digital ce sera l'une des premières
décisions entre autres effectivement ça
a été de mettre en route un vrai plan de
croissance pour saisir toutes les
opportunités que proposait finalement
cette période alors on a commencé par la
livraison à domicile puisque c'était la
première demande finalement des français
pendant cette période et on venait de se
le dire 25 % du territoire donc mon
ambition c'était 100% tout de suite du
territoire donc on l'a dressé d'abord
avec notre propre flotte que l'on avait
déjà et on a construit un partenariat
avec chrono fraîche pour aller couvrir
finalement le reste du territoire
français et on a commencé effectivement
à ouvrir un premier entrepôt en octobre
2020 également et puis on a mis en place
tout le click and collect donc on est en
train de déployer donc on a testé du
click and collect pour vérifier
l'appétence des clients à ce type de
modèle et puis janvier 2021 on a testé
aussi la livraison express notamment
avec des livres ou pour voir si là aussi
les sens pour nos clients et s'apprend
très bien ça prend très bien puisque nos
clients sont livrés en moins de dix
minutes voyez
et donc ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ça touche notamment les jeunes qui sont
une population qu'on voulait en tout cas
séduire dans notre enseigne donc donc
c'est intéressant donc pour attirer les
millénium notamment il faut plus de
digital évidemment il faut plus de
digital il faut varier les parcours
parce qu'on a une vie qui est multiple
on va tantôt au magasin tantôt ce fait
livrer tantôt on veut passer en click
and collect donc il faut savoir
s'adapter finalement parcours de vie des
clients la moitié des utilisateurs de
ces nouveaux parcours sont des nouveaux
clients pour la marque ne consommez pas
picard avant et qui on commence à le
faire via le digital et qui ont commencé
à faire via le digital et puis on avait
des des clients qui étaient fidèles à
nos magasins qui ont finalement mixer
comme on dit on les appelle les clients
omni canaux ceux qui sont à la fois en
digital et et en physique les rendre
justement hominick anovo clients c'est
ça aussi l'objectif qu'ils achètent à la
fois physique et aussi aux usa l'envers
on dépense plus quand on est à la
volaille en fait on est plus fidèle et
donc on dépense plus c'est chez nous
c'est deux fois plus voyons et en
inaugurant ce pas au détriment du
magasin e-commerce
s'apaisent a pesé quand vous êtes arrivé
2 % des ventes ça c'était avant
aujourd'hui ces quatre ça a doublé mais
ça reste seulement quatre pour son
objectif crois que c'est 10% en 2026
comment vous assurer que cet objectif
sera atteint comment m'assurer passé
comme je vous disais c'est x cours de
course voyez là le click and collect le
dpcp d'atteindre 10% horizon parce qu'on
se dit pour son final bon c'est 10 %
c'est pas rien mais c'est pas non plus
pas la moitié de ce chiffre d'affaires
qui en digital non c'est pas la moitié
contrairement à la chine la moitié de
son chiffre d'affaires des gens digital
pour vous donner la distribution
alimentaire absolument en chine mais on
est déjà 50% donc pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée sur la france en revanche
les produits surgelés représente selon
déjà 10% il était à 7% avant la crise
sanitaire ils ont une part de marché de
10% aujourd'hui donc finalement
atteindre les 10% ce serait rejoindre
une norme du marché à l'heure actuelle
cette crise a justement remis en avant
les bénéfices des surgelés alors certes
on se dit c'est stockables c'est
pratique mais pas sur mes pas que à
l'heure où justement l'environnement est
une préoccupation essentielle pour les
français
on vient de découvrir que les surgelés
c'était aussi une manière de ne pas
gaspiller finalement son alimentation
france ont juste besoin voyez on remet
le paquet au congélateur et on peut
conserver deux ans avec effectivement
des qualités gustatives et
nutritionnelles qui restent intacts
pendant ces deux années donc à l'heure
où effectivement les français se
préoccupe de lentilles gaspillage on
entend aussi nous on veut des légumes
cueillis en saison c'est le cas des
surgelés ou à en consommer en toute
saison pour autant toutes nos campagnes
de légumes de fruits sont fait
effectivement saison plus d'un million
de nouveaux clients c'est ce que la
crise sanitaire vous a permis de
conquérir comment est ce qu'on fait pour
les conserver est ce que le digital
c'est aussi un levier pour les conserver
oui alors il ya plusieurs matières
manière de les conserver il faut aussi
les anime et il faut les connaître déjà
donc la date ait une vraie réponse par
rapport à ça donc donc notamment via la
carte de fidélité donc on les connaît on
voit ce qu'ils consomment et il est
intéressant de leur poussée des produits
qui les intéressent donc avec nos
produits et on les reconnaît et c'est
typiquement ce que fait un programme de
fidélité donc on les anime
systématiquement par rapport à leur
fréquence de visite à leurs produits de
prédilection alors anniversaire aussi
nos clients adorent qu'on leur offre un
gâteau au chocolat à l'occasion de leur
anniversaire
vous voyez c'est effectivement tout un
processus de connaissance et de
reconnaissance et péladeau qui est pour
convaincre les clients potentiels qui
est qu'ils ne viennent pas encore chez
vous encore une fois le digital c'est
aussi une solution le digital est une
solution c'est pour ça qu'on est en
train de réfléchir à multiplier
différents parcours de course donc on
regarde ce qui se fait et notamment on
peut on ne peut parler peut-être du
snack-bar connectés qui effectivement
voilà qui est une innovation si digital
chez picard qui est ni plus ni moins un
distributeur automatique dans lequel
effectivement vous pouvez avoir recours
à des produits surgelés 17 ans tourne et
que l'on trouve dans des grandes
entreprises des parcs d'attraction des
hôpitaux et on a ouvert récemment des
universités aussi avec ce snack bar
connectés dans ce match l'objectif c'est
d'avoir un mariage aussi la maillage du
territoire important là où ça fait sens
donc
migaud y'en a mis 50 en france oui et
donc vous voyez l'objectif étant
finalement de multiplier les points de
contact avec nos clients sur tous les
instants de consommation il ya un avant
et un après dans l'accélération dans la
transformation digitale de chez picard
avec votre arrivée oui alors marque de
fabrique pas la seule mais c'est c'était
une décision forte priorité urgente
quand vous êtes arrivé oui absolument
donc je pense qu'il ya un avant et un
après pour les clients parce qu'ils ont
désormais accès à différents parcours de
course mais je pense aussi pour nos
équipes parce que aujourd'hui elles ont
la fierté finalement de tester
de nouvelles initiatives d'avoir des
résultats qui sont quand même
extrêmement intéressant on a fait une
année à +15 en progression de chiffre
d'affaires l'année passée donc donc on a
sur le marché ah oui je promets pas plus
15 tous les ans mais bon tout est permis
on s'est mis 2 milliards voilà 2
milliards de chiffre d'affaires en 2020
6 donc on a un plan de croissance
extrêmement ambitieux qui fait briller
les yeux de nos équipes avec la part
belle pour le digital merci en tout cas
cathy collart gère les agrégés de picard
[Musique]